hi in this video I will talk about qf q
a system in Rosalina so 2fq a system is
binary expression system just like gala
for us system choose team Drosophila
genetics so why do we at all need this
kind of binary expression system why why
we have a very well-established gal for
us system so in order to understand that
we need to diving there are two you know
one and you don't do and or hypothesis
was if you won one sacred some molecule
a and has a result it leads to a change
in neuronal activity in neuron - and
let's say we want to design an
experiment so as given is given one
secrets Michael a we can knock down the
protein a in your own one and look at
its effect on the postsynaptic neuron
you're on - and in the new one - we can
drive a calcium sensor whereas we can
drive our already I in you know one and
let's say we wanted to do it with care
for us system so exactly new one careful
is specific to new one it would also you
could drive a calcium sensor in the
second neuron green level but at the
same time the problem is since the u.s.
construction everywhere in the same so
the fly would also have us calcium
sensor driven in this particular unit
and also the gene a would be knocked
down in Iran - so our question cannot be
addressed in this kind of fashion
so one so in case of two component of a
circuit a same expression system is
actually overlapping with each other so
we need them not over
in expression system not overlapping
binary expression systems so let's say
we used the same thing but instead of
yeah through your system in the second
new one we used a qfq us system now Q
wave exactly is a driver and Q us is a
responder so exactly like gal 4 and us
system you have Q wave which is
equivalent to alpha and Q us which is
equivalent to us then what happens is Q
F doesn't drive us because it will be
drive Q us and also gal who doesn't
drive curious constructs so as a result
we have a more overlapping system and we
can address our question so let's just
see how this Q F and Q us system you
want so Q system is actually engineered
from Neurospora
thruster which is a clink mode and the
qh cluster has seven genes in it
what are these seven genes to our
regulatory and other files our genes
which are giving rise to metabolic
product important for ionic acid
metabolism
whereas q1f give rise to a transcription
factor which is known as qf + q1 s give
rise to another transcriptional
repressor which is nice Q s now what
happens is Q 1 if give rise to a
transcription factor QF it can allow
transcription from all the five genes
and we together ultimately lead to
production of the enzymes required
protonic acid metabolism but when the
glucose level is high then the
particular thing pool doesn't need to
metabolize panic acid so this whole
system should be repressed
so that time what happens Q 1 F is
transcribe is transcribing
but at the same time you have a
repressor so that's why the whole
cascade of gene is not transcribed but
think of a situation where kind acid is
present it would sequester repressor is
sequester the repressor and I love you
one F product qf to transmit all the
five chains and thereby making the
enzymes necessary for refining acid
metabolism so using this system it will
have devised a binary expression system
which is replaceable by Q s in
Drosophila now in this fly what happens
you have two components when it's a
driver flying one is a responder for the
driver fly you have the QF and you can
put the Q F which is a transcription
factor just like gas for the tissue
specific promoter but has the qus
between another flame unless they are
under tubulin promoter you can drive Q s
now Q s is a repressor of Q F now what
happens in the f1 generation QF is
produced but at the same time in the
media if kind of as it is absent then Q
s is actually going to prevent Q F from
transcribing any gene downstream to Q us
but when kind of case it is present in
the media then what happened is Q s is
sequestered and now Q F is free to
transcribe the gene on the line the Q us
underline the to us so we can understand
that using this kind of system we can
also achieve a spatial temporal dynamics
of expression so just like California
system and which is replaceable by
galaxy as well so that is the whole
utility of this kind of another second
binary expression system there are also
other binary expression systems like
Linux
so here is just a summary of how these
two systems are similar carefully u.s.
system and qfq AF system need multiple
of this system when we want to study the
interaction in a neuronal circuit or
let's say we want to understand that
once how one cell is behaving in the
neighborhood so this kind of questions
we need this kind of genetic tools which
is very useful this video was
informative and it helped you if you
liked my video give it a thumbs up
please subscribe and share thank you